Mike cernovich warned you Scott Adams
warned you and I said maybe a bit
aggressive fair but we now have
reporting from Newsweek that the FBI has
created a new extremist category and
that is Donald Trump's Army of Maga
followers that's right if you're a trump
supporter that's it the FBI has labeled
you an extremist let me say it again
Newsweek reporting the FBI has labeled
Trump's followers as extremists okay
I don't know where this goes I have a
general idea and maybe you might think
that cernovich and Scott Adams a little
over the top a little hyperbolic and
then you learn that uh well we knew
they're Prosecuting Trump's lawyers
they're issuing hundreds of thousands of
dollar fines against lawyers who
defended Trump they're going after Trump
allies they're falsely accusing people
across the board and have been for a
long time that's only getting worse and
now if you're a follower of trump
they're saying you're an extremist